das ist so hart bei diesem video selbst
wenn ich mich anstrengen würde ich
könnte euch nicht sagen wo der witz ist
ich kann sie nicht sagen servus sollten
entwicklung zu einem neuen wir leute ich
bin zurück aus dem urlaub ich war eine
woche an der nordsee ihr habt keine
videos gemacht haben mehr genutzt ein
bisschen ruhe zu haben aber bis zurück
wir sind
genauer gesagt sie mir zurück mit einem
zweiten teil von instagram quatsch denn
in einem video ist es unmöglich zu
behandeln was es alles an instagram für
scheißdreck content gibt es tricks
halbwegs passt ja ich will zeigen was
wir von direkt an max ich habe dinge
rausgesucht nicht schon alles gesagt
das ist auch schmerzhaft kann man das
sogar von neun gänge posten ein jahr
früher also eine seite heute da die war
sehr unterhaltsam früher war so die
ganzen - wirklich noch offline gelten
dann irgendwann so ich habe 2013 oder so
sie so richtig scheiße geworden
[Musik]
ohne witz mein erster gedanke dabei ist
einfach eigentlich keine lust mehr zu
existieren
das problem dabei ist nicht dass der
song schlecht ist und das problem dabei
ist dass sich jemand hingestellt hat und
in europa gewütet hat für lobo gekauft
und dann einfach gesagt hat ich mache
extra an schlechten song damit irgendwie
aufmerksamkeit bekommen und man kann
auch extrem schlechten song machen
pokémon geklettert so was apple und avid
also das ist in ordnung ja aber das
hatte ich lust sich das ist hier schon
durch würde sein also im echten leben
sagen soll ich machen soll
der wird extra schlecht und es geht
darum dass jemand kartoffelmarkt klar
wenn ich dich du [ __ ]
wenn er auf einem frauenparkplatz packt
und dann ganz ehrlich wenn schon smiley
in der überschrift von der post steht
rennt einfach geht irgendwann geht auf
eine andere seite
da kommt nichts bei raus aus dem magen
leitet ich bin gerade bei lidl parkplatz
ich wollte gerade beim mutter kind
parkplatz parken da habe es eine
pummelige her der mich auch gerade ganz
artig angrenzend tut weil er die
parkplatz weggeschnappt hat naja ihr
könnt mich an was er sei kein megafon
uns das mal so ein 10 euro
es hatte ja den lautsprecher direkt
unter dem mikrofon teil
das heißt man nur im auto der 88 schüler
so jedenfalls das was unsere coaches
goldenes mikrofon monolog über sicher da
standen die aufgabe sagt auch gern
sicherheit niemand was zu ihr gesagt hey
selbst statt dann niemals hätte die
fällt drüber geschwenkt angezeigt und
zensiert locken die band geht es auch
leute auf dem parkplatz steht gemischt
und dann bin ich einfach ein dass seine
person etwas was man nur im bereich im
haut hört lieber herr ja dann wurde mir
diese seite hier empfohlen von meinen
zuschauern fanny music ich hab mal so
allein die forscher hier über diese
beiträge verspricht schon trauer
na ja welches willst du von den seen
allein von den bildern her wie man sich
kainz anschauen aber welches bisher am
ersten ansturm recht scheint hans
entertainment moment zu gehen
[Musik]
was ist dann ab wer beim musical bis zu
eine pause aber trotzdem ich finde was
fehlt ist aus einem comic so diese
sterne über dem kopf also ausgenommen
spiels man stellt es die frage stellt wo
leute das donnerstag im comic wurde dann
vom lkw erwischt wird und danach direkt
danach wer hilft ihnen so eine hohe
alter geistig sein gesichtsausdruck man
so konzentriert dabei ist so als würde
gerade kleidung mit eine bombe unter
einem fußballstadion entschärfen
das drückt auf alles was er macht sich
kämpfen lassen wir kombinieren chef
natürlich einiges an meinem konnte
draußen sondern letzten video aber uns
fällt auf er macht nicht mehr die tage
videos was soll das ich will wissen was
passiert wenn sie 83 monate nach dem
zwanzigsten geburtstag ihre tage in
berlin
ohne spaß wir haben so ein problem und
oder meine von boca 40 sind ja schon
wüsste nicht was mit mir los ist sie mit
vor unterstrich hecking so weit ich
freue mich ja schon ein ich zittere
ergänzte sicht manchmal da gucke ich in
die sonne und es tut weh aber ich schau
trotzdem hinein
er ist das denn ich glaub ich hänge an
fall ja denke ich weiß dass noch was mit
dir los ich weiß es nicht ich kann
irgendwie nicht drauf schon mächtig was
los ist oder was
herzinfarkt text dieses wurde dieses
video gerne hingeht und überschritt ist
brown am morgen ohne kaffee zittert er
dann hat er jetzt ein herzinfarkt ich
bin nun macht gefällt bruder wir
brauchen kaffee oder ich bin noch dabei
ich wusste die cafeteria ich sehe das
überhaupt nicht weiß was ich erwartet
habe ich dachte so frauen am morgen ohne
kaffee und mir so ein kurzes video von
15 sekunden und sogar um mein gott ich
brauche meinen kaffee stadtpfarrer ja
sie braucht den kaffeetisch das ist das
mindestziel platz 3 0 keine chance wird
das haben leute was kann mir das ist so
hart bei diesem video selbst wenn ich
mich anstrengen würde ich könnte euch
nicht sagen wo der witz ist
ich kann es nicht sagen wenn wir jetzt
einer von euch die 10.000 euro das
verbieten will dass ich ihnen sage was
der witze über ist das war diese mini
leute abonniert auf jeden fall
radioshack-team einläufe was das geht ab
da haben wir eine folge über instrumente
wie gemacht also also die wir haben das
wissen erklärt ein paar sachen dazu
erzählt möchte lernen für alle dienste
werden